frozen to takes fans deep into the
unknown finally revealing the origin of
Elsa's powers honors future in arendelle
and the truth about what happened to the
sisters parents on that sea voyage
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm Jon and
in this video we'll be discussing the
epic ending of frozen 2 and how the new
movies mythology changes everything
about the past and future for elfs are
an honour and to celebrate the release
of the film and kicking off a new
giveaway for a chance to win subscribe
and keep watching for more details there
will of course be spoilers for frozen
too so take care if you haven't seen it
yet when frozen 2 begins three years
have passed since the castle gates were
opened and honor the quintessential
fairy tale character is still basking in
her happily ever after from the first
movie do you ever worry about the notion
that nothing is permanent
no and although deep down honor doesn't
want anything to change as she
demonstrates in the song some things
never change
the irony of the song's title is that
nothing could be further from the truth
Elsa is the catalyst for change when one
night she goes outside the castle to
explore the mysterious voice from the
north that keeps calling to her her song
into the unknown reveals the inner
turmoil Elsa feels she first resists the
siren song because she knows that
answering it will risk everything and
everyone she loves in arendelle the
voice challenges her though because it
understands Elsa's true destiny is not
to be queen of arendelle but to become
something else as Elsa realizes she
can't suppress her true calling any
longer she reaches out to the voice the
spirits answer back there with dramatic
effect and throw arendelle into disarray
as the earth and wind up down the
streets and blow the kingdoms
inhabitants out of the kingdom and up
onto the cliffs this event sets Elsa
Anna Olaf and Kristoff off on their
quest to the enchanted lands in search
of answers to the past find who is
calling to you they may have
as they parked the mist guarding the
entrance of the forest
Olaf remarks as an enchanted forest is a
place of transformation and as we'll see
all four characters will undergo a
significant change after their time
there inside the forest the gang meets
the arendelle Ian's and North Ultra
people who were trapped inside when the
spirits were angered and they also
learned that Elsa Nonna's parents met as
children in the forest
Elsa also discovers her mother's secret
connection to at a Harlan when Hanna
Marin explains that the four symbols on
a Dunas scarf represent each of the four
spirits and therefore a dunas connection
to nature a darker secret about Elsa and
Anna's parents is also revealed when the
sisters come across the wreckage of
their ship when else are extracts the
memories of what happened to the ship
from the water soaked into the wood they
learned that their parents didn't perish
in the seven seas as assumed but that
they were traveling to atta Harlan in
search of answers about Elsa's powers
the lullaby all is found is actually a
dune a secret message to Elsa and it
contains all the answers about the
themes of the movie and alice's destiny
when i was little my mother would sing a
song about a special river called
after holland that was said to hold all
the answers about the past about what we
are part of I so Harlan is the river
full of memory which contains the
answers to the past that Elsa is looking
for and so she goes to the shores of the
dark sea which she must cross to find
that River Fennell alibi after Elsa
tames the water spirit which appears as
a horse that challenges her to prove
herself worthy she rides it to utter
Harlan recalling the line from all is
found
come my darling homeward bound atta
Harlan is where Elsa's transformation
will occur she begins to sing show
yourself as she becomes overjoyed at
finding the place she truly belongs her
hair flows loose and free of any
constraints and as she enters into the
depths of the frozen glacier images of
her mother appear in the ice and both
Adina and the voice sing back to Elsa as
foretold and the lullaby all is found at
a halt and will sing to those who'll
hear and in her song all magic flows
as she travels deep into the heart of
the frozen river Elsa finally reaches
the symbols of the four spirits and
embracing the mythical magical moment in
the center of the four symbols a star
forms a symbol or sign of the fifth
spirit which is a union of all four
spirits this is very much Elsa's new let
it go moment and as she steps into the
center of the star it calls back to when
she stamped her foot on the North
Mountain and created a giant snowflake
that grew into an enormous ice palace
and just like in let it go when Elsa
created a new blue dress for herself in
show yourself Elsa's transformation is
completed but her magic creates a
stunning new white flowing dress this is
an amazing moment for Elsa and as the
fifth spirit her powers a tremendous but
as we will see she's not invincible as a
whole and opens up the memories of the
past and as Elsa goes deeper and deeper
into that past she gets colder and
colder as she discovers her
grandfather's betrayal of the North
ultra people Elsa's horror and fear and
guilt at uncovering this secret history
proves too much and she literally
freezes up with each memory she uncovers
in the end as the lullaby all has found
warned Elsa dives too deep into this
frozen river of memories and she drowns
in ice as the cold overcomes her so in a
change from the first film
apparently the cold does bother Elsa
anyway fortunately is previously
explained by honey Maren the fifth
spirit is also bridged between two
worlds and to prove this point just
before freezing over Alice ascends a ray
of magic to assist her honor
whose sheltering in a cave at that
moment the ice magic reveals the truth
about their grandfather to honor who
realizes what she must do to write the
historic wrong the arendelle Ian's
committed against the North ultra Anna
uses the earth giants to destroy the dam
that her treacherous grandfather built
which lifts the curse the spirits have
put on the Enchanted Forest and also
frees Elsa from her frozen state promise
me we do this together okay
I promise in the end then both honor and
Elsa were needed to break the curse and
restore balance to the world
because as Elsa points out their mother
had two daughters in fact Anna's heroic
moment was foreshadowed right at the
very beginning of the film when young
Elsa and Anna play with a mini enchanted
forest at the end of their game Elsa has
their fairy queen toy break the spell
saving everyone and honor adds that
everyone gets married
based on the previous films you'd
probably associate the magical Elsa with
the fairy queen toy they play with
however what happens when the girls grow
up is that it's honor who although not
magical herself is able to harness the
magic of nature like an authoritative to
used to do and by doing so saves
everyone by getting the earth spirits to
take out the dam with Elsa unleashed we
now get to witness the avatar or goddess
like powers that she commands with
arendelle under threat from the dams
flood waters Elsa summons and commands
the water spirit riding it to arendelle
where she stops and then dissipates the
tidal wave about to submerge the kingdom
now there's a lot more to discuss about
Elsa's tremendous new powers in frozen -
and a link to my full video on that here
and in the video description after
saving arendelle Elsa has an emotional
reunion with her sister Anna and echoing
her do you want to build a snowman
phrase from the first movie
Elsa resurrects Olaf from the pile of
snowflakes that he transformed into Olaf
faded away at the same time that Elsa
became frozen in utter Harlan because as
we know from frozen the magical snowman
was a result of Elsa's power so when she
passed he did - fortunately because
water retains memory as Olaf tells
everyone throughout the movie the little
snowman is restored with all his
previous memories the water that makes
up you and me has passed through at
least four animals before us
with her newfound sense of identity Elsa
also makes the momentous decision and
change to remain in the north and not
return to live in arendelle agreeing
with honey Marin suggestion that Elsa
belongs there now part of Elsa's
decision to remain in the north involves
asking honour to take over from her as
ruler and queen of arendelle fans will
no doubt debate this change of ruler but
it most likely works out best for both
sisters and was hinted at early in the
movie after arendelle was evacuated in
Grandpa be offered to look after the
errant aliens it was honor not Elsa who
displayed leadership and took charge of
giving orders to the troll leader I will
look after your people please make sure
they stay out of the kingdom until we
return of course this isn't to take
anything away from Elsa it's just that
honor is better suited to the more
constrained and human side of being in
charge for Kingdom whereas Elsa's
magical abilities and sense of mythic
destiny means she's better suited to
live near nature where she can freely
make use of her magic without causing
problems to those around her ultimately
Elsa has never felt fully at ease in
arendelle and her quest at a Harlan has
shown her were she truly belongs on the
other hand honor is perfectly suited to
life in arendelle and at the end both
set a regular date to meet up at the
castle every week never a dull moment
with you to another huge change for Anna
is that by the end of the movie Kristoff
finally manages to make his proposal to
her and they get married and on the
subject of honour and her happily ever
after ending we need to jump back a
moment and talk about her transformation
after she was separated from Elsa and
ended up alone in a cave with Olaf after
Anna receives the message from her
sister about their grandfather in the
dam bow LOF begins to flurry away and he
sadly reveals to honor that if the magic
is fading from him then her sister must
not be okay either honor then goes
through the heartbreaking moment of
holding her snowman friend in her arms
as he fades away knowing this also meant
her sister's life force was also fading
for honor who is an eternal optimist and
started the movie in such a happy place
these losses are heavy blows that sent
her into a deep sadness still she
manages to draw on her inner strength
and pull herself out of the depths of
dis
with her song the next right thing as
honor sings this emotional song she
determines that she can survive and get
through it
by moving forward one small step at a
time
through this transformation honor
matures into more complex character
which makes her even better suited to be
the new queen of arendelle and her
sister Elsa is now truly at peace with
her own powers to learn about all these
new powers and exactly what Elsa can now
do after frozen to tap here or click the
link in the video description to watch
my full breakdown of all of Elsa's new
powers so how do you feel about Elsa and
honors transformations in frozen - and
how do you think they could team up in a
future story share your thoughts in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe and hit the gleam link for a
chance to win an awesome frozen - Funko
pop the giveaway runs for the next four
weeks and the winner will be contacted
via email tapleft my next frozen - video
or tap write for another video you're
sure to like and if you enjoyed this and
a thumbs up and a share are hugely
appreciated thanks for watching and see
you next time you BK movie lovers